wir erleben das jetzt um uns herum in
großbritannien in den usa in saudi
arabien sogar in israel das impfen
losgeht mit einem in deutschland
entwickelten impfstoff wir brauchen so
schnell wie möglich die zulassung des
impfstoffs aber die muss auch auf einer
sorgfältigen prüfung basiert sonst haben
die menschen nicht das vertrauen in die
impfung und wenn die menschen sich nicht
impfen lassen dann hilft der impfstoff
an sich wenig deswegen brauchen wir so
schnell wie möglich eine sorgfältige
prüfung und zulassung der impfstoffe ist
also die briten haben unzuverlässigen
impfstoff die amerikaner die israel
halten sie mittags sagen dass ich heute
doch niemand aber es gibt regeln es gibt
regeln wann ein impfstoff in verkehr
gebracht werden kann und warum er denn
das land ist es lieber runzheimer auch
nicht so dass alle um uns herum impfen
weder in frankreich noch luxus sogar den
ersten deutschen der revolte in london
die arbeiten aber weder in frankreich
noch den luchs und mit einbrechern
entwickler hinsehen mag noch in finnland
noch in norwegen wird geimpft warum weil
wir eine europäische behörde haben die
zulassung dieses impfstoffs regelt wenn
er vertretbar und die einfach lama ist
als bei anderen behörden und auf dieser
welt wenn sie davon ausgehen wenn sie
davon ausgehen dass wir millionen
menschen impfen werden
und wenn du bei einem kleinen teil von
denen probleme entstehen dann haben sie
am nächsten tag die diskussion
wahrscheinlich auch bei ihnen in der
sendung hätte man nicht lieber noch
warten müssen am ende
am ende werden menschen in gefahr
gebracht weil sie an ihm kann sagen wir
jetzt eine sache inhalt meiner muss sich
unterbrechen dann sagen sie
bibi netanjahu boris johnson und
momentan donald trump spielen mit der
gesundheit ihrer bürger wir haben eine
verantwortung für unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger und wir wollen dass dieser
impfstoff so schnell wie möglich
verfügbar ist und dafür haben wir eine
behörde mit hervorragenden fachleuten
für ganz europa und die wird entscheiden
wann es losgeht und wir hoffen dass dies
in wenigen tagen der fall ist aber noch
einmal über gesundheitsrisiken können
wir wissen noch immer noch altmaier
entscheiden
auch nicht sie obwohl sie sicherlich
herausragende qualitäten haben das
müssen die ärzte machen die mediziner
die fachleute und auf deren
wer wir uns von habsburg